messing with the past may be
irresponsible but the flash gets a lot
of mileage out of Reviving past versions
of Batman here are all the small details
The Flash hid across its scattered
timelines
at the beginning of the flash Barry
Allen is waiting in line for a custom
breakfast sandwich when he gets a call
from Alfred pennyworth chaos has broken
out in Gotham City and Batman needs the
flash starving and already late for work
the ever complaining Speedster asks if
Superman might be able to lend a hand
instead however as both Alfred and a TV
broadcast tell him Kalel is busy
fighting a volcano while not quite overt
this moment can be read as a reference
to one of Superman's first cinematic
outings in the early 1940s Fleischer
Studios produced a series of animated
shorts starring The Man of Steel one of
these simply entitled volcano has
Superman saving people from the eruption
of well you guessed it given how many
past incarnation of soups are directly
referenced later in the film this feels
too spot on to be a coincidence it's
just a shame that fans couldn't catch a
glimpse of Henry Cavill one last time
Michael Keaton fans aren't the only ones
treated to some proper Batman action in
The Flash the opening set piece in
Gotham sees the Dark Knight chasing down
a gang of two-bit Crooks who have stolen
a dangerous pathogen it's the kind of
classic broad daylight chase that bat
Fleck never really got to do in his
previous movies and it evokes the
Christian Bale Batman movies in more
ways than one first and foremost there's
Bruce Wayne's heavy duty bat cycle which
Bears a striking resemblance to the one
Bale's character drives in the Dark
Knight and the Dark Knight Rises
hello
for a show tonight son but of course the
bat cycle didn't start with Christopher
Nolan there have been numerous
incarnations of Batman's motorcycle in
the comics dating back to the 1950s even
Robert Pattinson's Caped Crusader rides
one in the Batman albeit one that
actually fits with his Bruce Wayne Alter
Ego it's also worth noting that the
criminals Batman is chasing in this
sequence are led by another comic book
character the credits named their leader
as Al Falcone which is likely short for
Alberto Falcone in the comics the
villainous Alberto is the son of
notorious Gotham crime Lord Carmine
Falcone last portrayed in live action by
John Turturro in the Batman
though the name is never used and the
device itself is never constructed
Barry's method of traveling back through
time in The Flash evokes The Cosmic
treadmill one of the characters primary
methods of time travel in the comics the
treadmill was powered by cosmic energy
and designed to make jumping into the
past and future easy in The Flash TV
show a different version of the
treadmill appears playing a role in a
number of arrowverse events the movie
doesn't employ an actual treadmill but
the visual effect of Barry's time travel
seems intended to reference it once he
starts running fast enough he enters
what the films refer to as the Chrono
ball which lays out temporal events in
360 Degrees around him once there he
runs in place at varying speeds to
either go forward or backward in time
thus causing the surrounding events to
expand outward or collapse into him the
mechanic of running in place is sure to
make comic or arrowverse fans think of
the cosmic treadmill even though the
actual action is different
one of the most interesting tidbits
Dropped In The Flash occurs in a brief
exchange between Barry and Bruce after
Barry realizes that he can enter the
chronable and go back in time Bruce
tells him not to mess with the past as
doing so could unravel the very fabric
of reality
it still would be wildly irresponsible
I knew you were going to say this bury
counters by referencing the last time he
managed to change time in pizarnov the
Russian city from Justice League here's
the thing though Barry's one second jump
into the past at pizarnov only occurs in
the Snyder cut of the Justice League not
the original film Joss whedon's version
has Superman step in and defeat
Steppenwolf before he can activate the
mother boxes but in Zack Snyder's
version the villain wins forcing The
Flash to run back in time and prevent it
from happening by having Barry and Bruce
reference this event The Flash seems to
make the Snyder cut version of the story
Canon larger implications of that would
be the continued existence of Darkseid
the Green Lantern Corps and Martian
manhunter's partnership with Batman
since the new DCU is effectively
rewriting the whole movie timeline these
Revelations probably won't have any
resounding impact still it's curious to
see the franchise give canonical
Credence to the film's infamous
director's cut
if you thought that Warner Brothers
would be content simply to reference its
other DC properties in the flash think
again at times the movie becomes a
veritable Space Jam a new Legacy of
shoehorn nods to other WB Brands Barry
Allen's bedroom in the flashpoint
timeline is covered with movie posters
for other Warner Brothers films
including Pacific Rim V for Vendetta and
Inception his apartment is similarly
adorned featuring a Mars Attacks poster
and a computer monitor wallpaper of both
Mortal Kombat and Looney Tunes crazy how
everything Barry loves was produced or
distributed by WB isn't it one of the
key differences in the flashpoint
timeline that shows Barry just how
different things are concerns Back to
the Future in the new reality that Barry
creates Eric Stoltz plays Marty McFly in
the movie instead of Michael J fox if
you're familiar with the film you'll
know that Stoltz was indeed cast in the
leading role before Fox was brought on
in fact production began with Stolt
starring and continued for a number of
weeks eventually he was fired because
his acting style was deemed too serious
and fox was brought in to replace him
when the original Barry mentions Fox to
his doppelganger and his roommates they
say that fox actually appeared in
Footloose while Kevin Bacon starred in
Top Gun
General Zod is back just like in Man of
Steel he invades Earth with his
Kryptonian forces in search of a rebel
expat only this time that Target ends up
being Kara zorel instead of Superman
with Zod come a bunch of other specifics
from the Zack Snyder film the creepy
staticky announcement video that he
broadcasts to the world is the same one
seen in Man of Steel as is his ship his
power suit and the gear of his forces
this world must die one less overt but
certainly curious detail is the use of a
snap zoom in one shot of Zod and Kara's
battle The Cinematic technique is
prevalent in Man of Steel to the point
of being downright distracting and the
only instance of it in the flash occurs
during the duel with Zod
when Barry Allen arrives in the new
timeline he's created and discovers that
no one is stepping up to face Zod he
tries to find the rest of the Justice
League that proves more difficult than
he planned however as most of the heroes
simply aren't around Tamara Morrison
makes a cameo as Thomas Curry reprising
his role from Aquaman but his son Arthur
was never born in the new universe Barry
looks up Victor Stone AKA cyborg but he
discovers that his friend is still a
star football player this alludes to the
promising career detailed in Zack
Snyder's Justice League which was cut
short by the injuries that led to
Victor's cyborg rebirth without that
tragedy he never becomes a superhero
booyah
the absence of Wonder Woman can be
simply explained though it's brushed
over in the film since Barry's time
travel also affects the past it probably
changed things so that Steve Trevor
never crash landed on the mascara
thereby ensuring that the Amazons
remained hidden from the rest of the
world
the one Justice League member Barry and
Barry are able to track down is Batman
but not Ben Affleck's version instead
they infiltrate Wayne Manor to find
Michael Keaton's incarnation of the
character living in peaceful Solitude
and cooking spaghetti it seems that he
never hired more help to keep up the
property after Alfred passed away which
makes some sense given their bond and
with Gotham now one of the safest cities
in the world according to him he seems
to have no real calling in life anymore
of course he still has the bat cave
which proves to be a treasure Trove of
Easter eggs for fans of Keaton's Batman
movies when the two flashes first enter
the secret lair they're greeted by a
refrain of Danny elfman's iconic theme
music from the 1989 film and then they
discovered the Batmobile still arguably
the most famous version of the car right
where you remember it resting later on
the younger Berry discovers a more
obscure item a retro laughing bag prank
toy those who have seen Keaton's Batman
face off against Jack Nicholson's Joker
will know that this tool provided the
villain's last laugh
you dropped me into that vat of
chemicals that wasn't easy
to think that I didn't try after falling
to his death during the 1989 films
climax Joker's body still laughs at
least that's what appears to be
happening before the police retrieved
the bag from his pocket The Flash
indicates that Bruce held onto this
trinket either as a trophy or as a grim
remembrance
Michael Keaton's Batman has a lot of
gadgets gizmos and quick lines that pay
tribute to his Glory Days we see Bruce
open up a secret closet hidden in a
bookcase that houses a variety of
batsuits the central one is what he ends
up wearing for the rest of the movie but
viewers can also see his suits from
Batman and Batman Returns one that
resembles Adam West's costume from the
old Batman TV show and another with the
classic gray suit blue Cape scheme of
the comics among others once the rescue
mission kicks off we see the older Dark
Knights Tools in action grapple guns and
batarangs still get the job done and
Keaton's fight scenes are choreographed
in a flashy martial art style right down
to the perfectly emphasized punching
sound effects the Caped Crusader also
gets to drop some of his most famous
lines including
I'm Batman you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
the Kryptonian Rescue Saga in the flash
takes its outline from the flashpoint
Comics event but it's aesthetic from
Superman red Sun in the former Khalil is
captured and imprisoned by a secret U.S
government organization after Crash
Landing in Metropolis as a baby brutally
experimented upon in a bunker far away
from the Sun he's eventually rescued by
the team of Batman Flash and Cyborg it's
easy to imagine how the scene would have
played out in the movie had Ray Fisher
not been ousted from the project
stands the secondary takes Cyborg's
place there are two big differences in
the movie version however the first and
most obvious one is that its cars or L
and not Kalel who's imprisoned and
rescued the other difference is that
she's trapped in a Russian mercenary
facility instead of a U.S government lab
this shift in political geography could
be seen as a reference to Red's son the
acclaimed Superman storyline that
imagines him Landing in the Soviet Union
instead of America
the ending of The Flash features a
massive battle between the U.S military
zod's forces and a hodgepodge Justice
League consisting of Batman Cara and two
flashes we see that fight numerous times
as the two berries run back the clock to
try to get a win it doesn't work but
their efforts pull hard on the fabric of
space-time yanking in a variety of other
Chronicles from parallel realities
that's when the Easter eggs really ramp
up the first Universe features a black
and white Superman playing tribute to
late star George Reeves and his
Adventures of Superman TV series from
the 1950s at the center of this Chrono
bowl is Jay Garrick played by Teddy
Sears he's the original Flash and he
even has his winged hat Sears previously
portrayed a version of Garrick in the
arrow vs Flash show though that
character wasn't exactly the true J
another world features Christopher Reeve
Superman from the 1970s and 80s movies
who appears alongside Helen Slater's
Supergirl from the 1984 film of the same
name Even Adam West's Batman makes a
cameo popping in from his beloved retro
TV world
you may return to your business citizen
[Music]
the biggest surprise in the big space
time climax of The Flash is the
appearance of Nicholas Cage's Superman
who was meant to appear in the late 90s
film Superman lives but neither the
character nor the film ever made it to
the big screen Tim Burton was set to
direct the picture and extensive
pre-production work was done but the
project eventually fizzled out Cage's
look in the flash is true to how the
character would have looked in the
canceled film the scene in which cages
Superman appears is also a tribute to
the unfilmed script which reportedly
would have featured a fight between
Kalel and a giant spider that's exactly
what the character is seen fighting in
the flash it's very silly but also quite
fun and a nice nod to one of the biggest
superhero movies we never wound up
getting
the ultimate villain of The Flash ends
up being Barry Allen himself yes the
freaky purple monster that knocks him
out of the Chrono Bowl near the
beginning is in fact an aged version of
berry driven mad through ages of trying
to save his timeline this warped version
of the character doesn't get a new name
in the film but he's evocative of a few
different incarnations from other Flash
stories the closest point of comparison
would probably be the version of The
Flash in Robert venditti and Van
Jensen's Out of Time comics Arc with art
by Brett booth and Ron France in that
storyline a version of Barry from the
future attempts to write a series of
perceived wrongs through the past but he
only ends up causing more chaos in the
speed force and the timeline fans more
familiar with the CW's Flash series
might have thought of the villain's
savitar who's revealed to be a future
version of Barry gone bad
monstrous form in the show is
reminiscent in some ways of the
purpleberry in the movie but the two are
admittedly quite different in their
backstories it s also worth noting that
savitar isn't actually very in the
comics so it's possible that the new
film took direct inspiration from the
arrowverse
when Barry finally gets back to his
original timeline everything seems to be
set right a slight tweak in the course
of events allows his imprisoned father
to be exonerated but other than that
things are just as they were at least
until Bruce Wayne shows up to
congratulate Barry on the victory in
court it isn't Ben Affleck's Batman it
isn't Michael Keaton's Batman it isn't
even Robert Pattinson's Batman now
instead The Flash pulls a fast one via a
cameo from Batman and Robin star and
Cinema Legend George Clooney the 1997
film is widely considered one of the
worst superhero flicks of all time the
Gap in time between it and 2005's Batman
Begins has been blamed directly on its
poor reception but over the years the
film has taken on an almost cult-like
status for its hilarious writing and
campy Style
six million seven million
never leave the cave without it
with all that history in mind it's fun
to see Clooney back in the role of Bruce
Wayne and it helps that he's still a
huge movie star who oozes charm and
Charisma basically everywhere he goes
you know like Bruce Wayne so maybe
Clooney wasn't such a bizarre casting
Choice after all
[Music]
foreign